[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, everybody.
Happy Thursday.
Welcome to the Data
Science Hangout.
I hope everybody is
having a great week.
If it is your first time
joining us here today, hello.
Very nice to meet you.
I'm Rachael.
This is an open space for the
whole data science community
to chat about data
science leadership,
questions you're facing, getting
to hear about what's going on
in the world of data science
at different companies
across different industries.
And so, every week we feature
a different data science leader
as my co-host here to
help lead our discussion
and answer questions
from you all.
So together, we're all
dedicated to making
this a welcoming
environment for everybody.
And I love when we can hear
from everyone, no matter
your level of experience
or area of work.
It is totally OK to just listen
in if you want or participate
in the chat.
There's always
three ways you can
ask questions or provide
your own perspective
on certain topics too.
So one, you can always jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom.
You can put questions
into the Zoom chat.
You can always put a
little star next to it
if you want me to
read it instead.
And then, third, we
also have a Slido link
where you can ask
questions anonymously.
And I'm sure Hannah is
sharing that in the chat
here right now.
And just to note, we do share
the recordings of each session.
So you can always go find them
up on the Posit YouTube or also
the Data Science Hangout site.
And one last thing, we do have
a LinkedIn group for the Hangout
too.
So if it helps you with
connecting with people
or finding each other, we'll
share that in the chat as well.
But thank you so much,
Yu, for joining us today.
My co-host joining
us is Yu Cao, VP
of Data Science
at Exeter Finance.
Hello, everybody.
Hey.
And Yu, I'd love love
to kick things off
with having you
introduce yourself
a little bit about your role,
and maybe because rock and roll
was included in
your bio, I'd like
to know who your
favorite band is too.
Sure.
[LAUGHS] OK, sure.
Of course.
First, I want to thank
Rachael and her team
for organizing the hosting and
also giving me the opportunity
to host a session.
As a data scientist,
I always believe
that it's super
important for people
to stay connected to
the whole community.
And that's why today I want
to have an opportunity to talk
to all of you guys here.
And then, let me do a little
stuff introduction myself.
I'm Yu Cao.
I'm from China.
[ECHO]
Sorry.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: Sorry.
One second.
There's a little echo.
I'll mute somebody.
There we go.
So I'm from China.
So you can hear that.
And you can tell that English
is not my native language.
So if there is something
I didn't speak clearly,
please feel free to let me know.
Probably Rachael can
also help me out.
So right now, I'm the
VP of Data Science
at Exeter Finance, which
is a subprime auto lender.
I'm also an EMBA student
at Cornell University.
And so, today, these
are the two topics
that I want to share
with you guys about.
We can talk about how we use
data science in a finance
industry, how we use
data science to manage
the portfolios to
manage the default risk.
And also, I want
to share with you,
why do I share
with you guys, why
do I believe that to
pursue in big ways
is still super
important for the career
development for the department
of leadership for data
science people.
But before we reached--
before we go into that topic,
I can talk a little
bit about myself.
My background is biology.
Actually, I have my
undergraduate degree
in biotechnology.
And I have my masters
in biochemistry
in the United States.
And after that,
I decided, I want
to pivot to another
industry, which is
operations research
and data science.
So I got my second master's
degree in operations research
in 2010.
And after that, I work in the--
I work as an analyst.
I work in the
analytical industry.
So I started as an
analyst and then
transitioned to data
scientist, and then
manager of data science,
senior manager of data science,
and eventually VP
of data science now.
And a bit, probably a little
bit fun fact for myself,
because when I see Rachael's
self-introduction, and Rachael
said, that I play guitar.
I said, OK, this is
just me, I like guitar.
I like rock and roll a lot.
So I play guitar like an
immature, but I like it a lot.
So maybe I started--
it was-- I started
in maybe 2000.
I was a high school in China.
And then I saw-- happened to
saw famous video of "Smell
Like Teen Spirits," by
Nirvana on Chinese television.
And this song resonates with
my personality and my character
so well.
I started from then, I
maybe spend four or five
years listening to rock roll
crazily, I would say that.
Maybe I would spend
five, six hours
everyday just listen to
all this type of music.
Maybe you remember, iPod used
to have 160 gigabyte iPod.
It can hold more
than 40,000 songs.
And this is just a product
for people like me.
[LAUGHS]
So I spent a lot of time
on rock and roll music.
I listened to the music.
I wrote music reviews, album
reviews for some online forums,
I even published it in
some music magazines.
I started for four
or five years.
And when I came to
the United States,
so after I graduated
with my master's degree,
I got to entry level
job as an analyst.
And during that time it's
for me it's kind of like a--
I would call it, I have
two phases in my life.
So during the daytime,
I work as an analyst.
I was very analytical,
very rational, very nerdy.
But probably after
work, after 8:00 PM,
I got changed, put on my
all my punk rock gear.
And then, I don't know whether
other people-- by the way,
I'm from Dallas, Texas.
I don't know whether other
people in the audience
from Dallas, Texas too.
In Dallas, there is a
famous district called
Ti Pao in the downtown area.
There are a lot of music clubs,
pop, rock and roll shows,
all the concerts held up there.
So I spent a lot
of nights there.
So probably especially
every weekend.
So after 8:00 PM I
just go-- went there.
I joined the concert.
I hang out with a lot of
rock and roll bands there.
From there I meet a lot of my--
a lot of bands I idolized, like
[NON-ENGLISH],, Sonic Eagles,
all these bands.
So I just hung out with them.
And then probably until 1:00 AM.
And the next day I
just go back to work.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I love that.
And then, such life
continued for five years
until maybe 2015.
There was a milestone.
I got married.
So after that, I
since change a lot.
So instead of go to having
my regular nightlife
like every day or every
other day, probably
I can't go to a concert
show maybe other bands.
That's bad.
I remember the first
show I tried to brought
my wife to the first show.
It was a show by the
WHO and Junkyards
at the American Airline Center.
And after that
she told me, oh, I
can't believe that you listen
to that kind of noisy music.
[LAUGHS] So I kind
of decide, probably I
need to stop going to
a concert that often.
And then, so since then,
I can only go to a concert
once a month.
And then in 2017,
another thing happened.
So my wife was pregnant
with our first son, William.
So I remember, I
can still remember,
my last concert I
went was in May 2017.
That's the last one.
And then William was
born in January 2018.
And then, so it's just
very busy, just crazy.
The first year was just crazy.
And then in 2020, William
was almost two years old.
I thought, he is old enough.
He can sleep at
night by himself.
Probably I can go back to my
music life a little bit more.
And then, you know what
happened, the pandemic.
So everything closed.
All this rock and roll clubs,
the famous, the Tourist,
Club Dada, Pub Factory,
everything was closed.
So I had to, of course, I
had to put the plan on hold.
And sadly, right now,
a lot of the clubs,
they never reopen again
due to this shock.
And then--
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: So, I have
to ask you, do you ever
mix music and data science now?
Absolutely.
Yeah, I can finish
that very quickly.
So after that, for me,
data science is a science.
But I also want to talk
to people in my team.
So if you want, you really do
it-- want to do it very well,
treat it like an art,
not just science.
In order to be a very
good data scientist,
I believe we all
need to be creative.
And I believe the creative
all need to possess
some artistic creativity.
And for me, for
myself, the creativity
comes from the music.
I love it.
I absolutely love live music
and finding live music.
So now I know who to ask
for recommendations whenever
I go to Texas then.
Sure.
So we can't put an ending to
talk about my music life here.
So probably, we can start
to talk about data science
or my experience as an analyst.
RACHAEL DEMPSEY:
Yes, absolutely.
Hey, we're good with making it
a rock and roll hangout too.
But Yu, I'm really curious,
while we wait for questions
to come in from everybody, what
made you so interested in data
science from the beginning?
Oh, I just resonate
with my nature.
So I'm an analytical person.
I'm more focused on details.
And I like to find
a patterns from data
and then use it to
make predictions.
And I like to work with
people from the academia,
like from universities, or from
the research team of big tech
companies.
So everything fits perfect
as a data scientist.
So that's why I started my
job as a data scientist.
What has the progression
been like for you,
moving from an analyst,
to data scientist,
to leading a data science team?
The first thing that because
when I work as an analyst,
most of my job is
ad hoc analysis.
So I pull data, I
build the reports,
I do some other analysis,
and present my results
to the leadership team.
However, I later found out,
so instead of just doing
something ad hoc, I want to
do something more systematic.
Again, I'm always--
because my second degree
was the operations research
as basically mass modeling.
So I still want to
build models for all
the other analytical jobs.
And because my first job was
for a healthcare company.
So at that time I
wanted to see, so can we
use all the data to predict
the behavior of patients?
And I started-- I built
my first predictive model
during that time.
And after that, I feel that
this is what I want to do.
So that's why I
want to pivot to--
and it's a little-- it's a small
pivoting from analyst to a data
scientist.
And then after that,
because I changed to--
I switched to a financial
service company.
So our company doing
subprime loans,
and which is
subprime auto lender.
Because if you want to buy a
car, you'll go to a dealership.
And if you can not
pay cash, you'll
need to apply for a car loan.
And because if your credit
score is not that well,
for our definition, subprime
means that people with credit
score less than 620.
And then for that
customer segment,
there are a lot of risk there.
So you need to build a
lot of predictive models
of predictive rates at that
price to manage the price,
manage how we
servicing the loan,
how we originate the loan.
So this is why our entire
subprime lending business
is driven by data science.
And because of this, I feel
that I have my knowledge
and my detail, my interest,
plays a super important role
for the business.
So that's why this is
the industry I like.
And then I started
as data scientist.
And gradually I feel, it's
not just about modeling.
So you can just
sit there building
model coding every day.
But this is the most basic work.
So if you want to
do it really well,
you need to understand
the business part.
You need to understand, so what
problem the business is facing?
And how can you formulate
a business problem
into a data science problem?
And then, build a model
is also the simplest part.
And then, with this,
and then I tried
to started to spend
my time to collaborate
with all the other
teams in the company,
try to understand their world,
how is the sales team working?
How is the marketing
team working?
How is the origination
teams working?
And but gradually, because
I have more understanding
of the business, I gradually
move up in the career
hierarchy, I'll call it.
And after I become senior
manager of data science,
I feel my data science
knowledge is not enough.
So if you go to a higher
level, it's not about coding.
It's about not
about data science.
Suddenly, you'll need some
hard skills from other areas.
For example, you need to
understand accounting.
You need to understand finance.
You need to
understand marketing.
And for all of these, I need
to learn something probably.
Of course, ideally you can
also outsource these skills.
Because if you are a leader,
you need some accounting,
hire accountant.
You need some
financial knowledge,
hire financial manager
or financial analyst.
And if you need marketing,
hire a marketing manager.
These hard skills,
you can outsource.
But they are also another
part of, probably,
I call them soft skills.
You can only do it by yourself.
For example, how to
build a productive team.
How to, for example, how to
do business negotiations.
All these skills you cannot
outsource them to other people,
let other people help you do it.
You need to do it yourself.
And that's why I decided I
need to go back to school.
I need to pursue
an EMBA program.
Probably this is the
best time for me.
And I started program last
year at Cornell University.
And later, if you
are interested,
I can explain why I think
that this program feeds--
a lot of people in
the audience who
are aware because of its
format and because of its goal.
And so, but right now,
Rachael, I go back to you,
see if you have any question.
Yeah, absolutely.
And I know we
shared in the chat,
if you want to ask questions
anonymously, you can use Slido.
But feel free to just
raise your hand here
if you want to jump in
the conversation too.
But Yu, I love the
way that you explain
working with different
parts of the business
to actually understand
the business problems.
And I was wondering what that
process looks like for you
of building relationships
with different people
across the business.
Is it like joining
some of their meetings?
How do you go about that?
Actually, it all
started with networking.
Because networking,
I know a lot of it,
because I work with very
analytical, I would say,
a very nerdy team.
So a lot of the people there
are, I just want to code.
I want to build a
fantastic model.
I do not want to spend too much
time to network with people
from other business lines.
But actually, this is
probably, I would say,
it's not the right attitude.
Because if you want to
collaborate with other people,
first you need to
get to know them.
You need to understand how
their businesses-- and yeah,
another word, probably
most, is actually you
need to become their friends.
So usually I reach out
to them and say, do
a self-introduction.
And this is what I do.
This is what my team can do.
So let's go out for lunch.
Let's go for-- let's
grab a cup of coffee.
Let's talk for 15 minutes.
Let's see what
kind of business--
what kind of
difficulties you are
having now in your business.
If you are a sales
team, are you worrying
about how to increase
the volume of sales?
If you are a loan
originations team,
are you worried about how to
increase the capture rate?
And then, let's talk about that.
Then I will see, how can
I connect my data sets
knowledge with the problem
you are facing now?
See whether I can build
a model to help you
solve that problem you have.
Usually, the collaboration
starts with this.
And when you build
a model for them,
how do you share that with them?
What does that look like?
Well, I would say
that probably I think
that's a very important part.
Because data scientist has to
be a wonderful storyteller.
It's easy to build a model
today because we have AutoML,
we have very automated
pipeline that basically we
can't have it later.
So we design our
model on the pipeline,
or like a streamline
assembly line.
So basically, even if you have
no knowledge of data science,
you just change some
hyper-parameters,
and they'll click a button,
of course, in RStudio.
And then, after two
hours or two days,
depends on the size
of your data set,
you can get a bunch of models.
And a lot of them, mostly
this model performs well.
But this is only the beginning.
And then, the difficult
part is that you
need to sell these models,
like your own product.
You need to let the business
owners, stakeholders, buy
this model.
You can build a very
good model, a risk.
However, you need to be able
to let your dealer sales
managers understand this model.
And they have to be-- they
should be able to explain this
to the dealers.
I cannot reach out to
our dealers, I build--
this is a model I built
measuring your risk.
They won't buy it.
Dealers are, no, we don't
want to hear about it at all.
So the dealer-- so the model
needs to be transparent,
need to be explainable,
and to be that,
to do that, usually, my approach
is starts from the easiest one.
So usually, if we build
a new model, for example,
either to help
for the sales team
or measure the risk
of dealers, usually we
start with a simple
logistic regression model.
Because, frankly, everybody
understands a little bit
about logistic regression,
or pretends that they
understand logistic regression.
[LAUGHS]
So usually, if we present a
logistical regression model,
there won't be a
lot of pushback.
They will say, OK,
I understand that.
Just tell me about
all the variables.
And then, if the direction
the variables make sense,
we'll buy it.
And we can explain that to
the dealers, to the end users.
And after that, when you build
some relationship or trust
with your customers or
the user of these models,
then later you can gradually
push things forward.
I would say, so next time we
can have some machine learning
algorithms.
The models we build using these
algorithms perform better.
They are more predictive.
And they are explainable.
We can try to show--
try to show that,
show you how to explain that.
And they are 100%
compliant because we are
in highly regulated industry.
So everything we
build, we are already
audited by the people from the
government annually every year.
We say, they will check
all the models we'll
build, to see whether
this is discriminatory,
whether all the variables
we use are compliant.
And we are sure that the
model is fully compliant,
is fully transparent,
and is accepted by--
I won't say accepted
by the entire industry,
but it's accepted by a lot
of players in the industry.
So because we are
not the biggest
company in the industry.
We are probably the third
or fourth-largest subprime
lenders.
So our company,
well, our leadership
is a little bit conservative--
their culture is.
So what we always
say, we have a model,
this is the algorithm
we just figure out.
They will try to say,
are we the first one
using this in the industry?
If the answer is
yes, they probably
say, oh, probably
we should wait.
And if we said, probably Capital
One is using this right now.
Or maybe Santander, maybe--
is using this right now.
They will say, OK,
then let's go ahead.
[LAUGHS]
I see there's a lot of
love for logistic regression
in the chat there.
[LAUGHS] But Alan, I see
you just asked A question.
Do you want to jump in?
Sure.
Yeah.
Hi.
I'm really curious about how
your organization has treated
your shift in roles from
individual contributor
to a VP of data science?
And curious if-- what's
that meant for you in terms
of figuring out what is
my mission at each stage,
and whether you had to
create that for yourself
as you became VP, or if that was
already a well established role
that you could
slide into and know
what success looks like there.
How did you make
those transitions?
You talked a little bit about
leadership and about the
learning the business stuff.
But I'm wondering, did
the organization help you,
or were you on your own
to go, oh, I'm a VP now.
What does that mean?
Thank you very much, Alan.
First, very good question.
And to explain
that, first of all,
I will say that my
leadership of the company,
they are super supportive for
my growth for my transition.
And they provide a lot
of help, either help
from the perspective
of leadership
to help me to get exposure
to senior leadership
and help me learn a lot of
things on how to lead a team,
how to work with other
teams, and they even
provide some financial
help for my EMBA study.
And on the other
side, our company
is not a very big company.
So a lot of the time,
you need to-- and so,
I'm the first VP of,
I would say, yeah,
I'm the first person to hold
the title VP of data science
in the company.
So basically, I need to
build a lot of procedures,
processes all by myself.
It's kind of now I have a
team of data scientists.
And I need to define
my own function.
So now you are VP
of data science now.
So it doesn't make sense
you're still sitting there
building models every day.
You need to do something else.
Because you should dedicate
these jobs to your reports.
Yes.
And then, I figure
out, the goal I
made for myself is
that as a leader,
as a VP of data science, the
most important thing for me
is to grow my own team.
So I have some data
scientists that report to me.
My goal is that I want to let
them know that so one day you
will be in my shoes.
I won't be there forever.
And one day you will
move up, up, up,
and then you will be here.
And then, in order
to be prepared,
I want you to start to
either advise your own self,
you need to make
clear career goals,
what you want to achieve in the
next three years, five years,
not just from a technical
standpoint, no stress.
OK, I want to master how
to build posting models,
how to propose some innovations
to our current model,
your own process, not just that.
I want them to make
goals on their behaviors.
Like how to, I mean, how to
develop their own leadership
skills, how to engage, how
to create opportunities
for themselves to be a leader.
And I will be 100%
supportive for their growth.
I believe this, right
now, this is my goal.
So for me, probably I
will say that maybe--
when my post, my
own performance,
I will say that 50% just
measure the output of myself
and my team.
And another 50% are to--
I want him to focus
on how I invest on
the growth of my own team,
how everybody in my team,
how they grow.
How are they, I
mean, how are they
making progress in
their own career path.
I feel this is super important
for me as leader right now.
That's great.
Thank you.
I really, really
like hearing both
that you had support coming into
the role, like good enablement,
and also a bunch of room to
figure out what it looks like.
And being supportive
to do all of that stuff
on behalf of your team in
terms of their development,
that doesn't happen everywhere.
And it's not easy.
And so, yeah, I
really appreciate
hearing your thoughts on that.
Thanks.
Yeah.
And again, probably the
company is still small enough
so I have a lot of room.
I can make a lot of
decisions all by myself.
So it means that if
you can call the shots,
it means that you are afraid
to build what you want to do.
Cool.
Thanks.
Thank you.
I was talking with someone just
this week who is starting to--
well, wants to build
up their data science
team within their
organization and wants
to move into that VP of
data science role that
doesn't exist yet today.
And I'm wondering if you have
any recommendations for where
to start [LAUGHS] with that?
I think there are so many
different things for people
to think about when you start
off at this blank slate where
you could have any tools
or any infrastructure.
It can be overwhelming
to know where to start.
If you mean you want
to build a data science
team from scratch, I
would say that first you
figure out what your team
can do for the business.
It's not if data
science can have
little to do for
the business and can
create very little values there,
that it doesn't make sense
for you to build a team there.
You need to go to a
new company probably.
And if there is a need,
so if you're figuring out,
for data science can
create this value,
this value, this value
for the business,
then first you need
to, I would say,
do some public
relations component.
You need to let everybody, all
the leaders in the company,
understand this.
So usually, for example,
for my EMBA education,
they usually ask
you to do feedback.
So they ask you to reach
out to the leaders,
your coworkers in the company.
And you ask them to provide
feedback for yourself
and then probably
you also can say,
my goal is to build
a data science team.
My goal is to become a data
science leader in this company
in the next year.
So what I need to do?
And this is most important.
So everything starts
from the people,
from buy-in from other leaders.
If you can build this, if you
can let other leaders, which
are going by, OK, this guy, the
word of this guy makes sense.
Probably if we invest in data
science, we can achieve this,
and this, this for
the business, is
highly valuable for
the business itself,
and the company will
eventually rise on this.
And another thing is that
to help, if the person just
wanted to say, I'm a
scientist, I want to grow up
to a leadership
position, how could I
persuade the company--
convince the company that I'm
the right person?
And I would say that besides
good results, of course,
you also need to make
sure to show them
that you can always do a good
job whenever they need it.
And the other thing is
that you need to show
the ambition to the leadership.
This is my takeaway, that
is that especially right now
that the job market for
data science is hard.
So this is the right time
for you to show the company,
I want to invest on my own self.
I'm not just want to be a data
science doing coding, building
models.
I want to enlarge my influence.
I want to learn more things
about the whole business.
I want to move up.
I want to be a leader
of a large organization.
And usually, when you do
that, the company will realize
your ambition, will
realize your value,
and usually it will
generate good results,
good feedback from the leaders.
And actually, this
is what I did.
I remember that
when I said, when
I reach out to the leadership
of the company and said,
I want to pursue my EMBA
degree, and I need your help.
It will be a big commitment.
I need a financial support.
And also, it will take a lot
of my time, hard-earned time.
And the leaders, after hours of
discussion, they believe that.
So of course, I know that
probably in the next two years
you'll be busy, your
time will be so on,
but we feel that it shows that
you are really understands--
you want to understand
more about business,
and you really want to
do more to contribute
to the entire organization.
I think that's why
they decide, it's
good time to invest on
you as our employee.
Thank you very much.
It's really helpful.
I see Katherine, you had
asked a question a little bit
earlier in the chat.
Do you want to jump in next?
Yeah.
I was curious how
you stay on top
of best practices in machine
learning or new techniques
that you can use data science
techniques as you transition up
that ladder and you
start focusing more
on big picture things.
I know within my
own career, I've
been finding it more
difficult to stay
on top of the new model
that's going to achieve
the same thing
that I know about,
but my knowledge is even
six months out of date.
So how do you navigate that so
that you stay informed and can
properly manage your
team or understand
the models that they're
giving back to you?
Thank you, Katherine.
That's a perfect question.
So this is probably
relates to one
of my further part of my job.
So I act as the ambassador
of the data science team of--
So basically, because
I spent time in--
I spent a lot of
time in universities,
I was first in a PhD program,
but I dropped out with a master
and switched to the
analytical program.
And because of that, I love
to work with academic people.
So probably I built
a lot of connections
with people in universities.
They are maybe PhD students.
They are post-doc researchers.
They are professors,
or research scientists
from either Microsoft,
Facebook, these ones.
So usually, every other week
or every month I will go online
and I review the
latest publication
in machine learning,
data science.
Of course, I will search
using some keywords make sure
that they're
related to my topic.
And then, usually,
after that, if I
find something interesting,
I will reach out
to the author of the publication
and I will have a discussion
and say, so I read something
really interesting.
Could you share some codes?
Could you maybe-- maybe we
can even have a meeting.
We can talk about
if we want to try
to implement the algorithm
you proposed to our industry.
Let's see what we can do here.
And it generate good results.
For example, I remember in
20-- let's see, yes, 2020.
I don't know whether
you guys know,
there is a Python package,
auto machine learning package
developed by a Microsoft
team called FLAML, F-L-A-M-L.
It's called FLAML,
what does mean?
I forgot what it means--
actually it's light--
fast, lightweight auto ML.
Yeah.
At that time, the
product was just
released maybe two
or three months.
So it's completely new.
It's kind of 0.1
version, version 0.1.
And I happened to
find this product.
And I found it fits
our needs perfectly.
And I had a lot of conversations
with the development team
back and forth, back and forth.
And they are super nice.
They are super responsive.
They work super hard.
And all of them are research
scientists in Microsoft.
And then I go them
otherwise, because I
know that's a good product.
But we are all financial
service industry.
And if we want to
use it, we need
this feature, this feature,
this feature add in.
And then they said, OK,
we can have, like, have--
And I keep giving
them the feedback.
So after this feature,
after this feature,
how it helps our model to learn
the process or the workflow.
And then, gradually,
finally their product
got better, and
better, and better.
Right now, it's two years
from the first version--
more than two years.
The product is very
popular right now.
And it become, I will say, very
crucial, very critical part--
critical component of our
model and pipeline right now.
So I will say, this is one part.
So that's the first
part of my question.
So if I want to
keep on top, stay
informed of all the latest
research, all the latest
programs in the machine
learning industry,
just try to read
some papers, try
to keep in touch with other
researchers in the university.
Because if there are some new
discoveries, new programs,
they are driven by them.
And secondly, for my team, there
is, first, I also request them,
so every year, every
month, or every quarter,
you need to spend some
time to read these papers,
this research progress.
And also, I give
them some freedom.
So probably you can
use 10%, 15% real-time
to do something you
believe that will
be useful sometime
in the future,
but not necessarily
useful right now.
As long as you can justify
it, as long as you can tell me
why you want to
check this out, why
you want to type this
algorithm, it's OK.
Probably we can not
use it right now.
If you want to show me you won't
build a deep neural network
model or something like that,
it will performs very good,
that's great.
Right now, our industry
you cannot use that model
because of the--
I mean, it's not compliant
because of the explainability.
But probably in the
future sometimes
you will be able to use it.
We always has our
preparation for the future.
And again, in this
whole process,
I believe all the
matching members,
have then their own
creativity and thinking.
We also want to do the research.
They all think
about the business,
what kind of the model,
what kind of algorithm
I should try to match
with the business,
to try to match with
what I'm doing right now.
And so, by doing
this, I'm trying
to make sure that all people in
my team, they are also keeping
informed, keeping
informed of all the latest
programs in the machine
learning industry.
I love how much you
point toward networking
when you are both talking
about working with the business
but also in keeping up to date.
And I see, Libby, I think
you just called that out
in the chat as well.
And I think it's a skill
that we don't often
highlight through, I don't
know, interviews or on a resume,
your ability to network
and get ahead through that.
YU CAO: Yeah.
KATHERINE GERTON:
And I wanted to add
that I like the idea of--
I like to keep
continuing education
as one of my
personal career goals
and as the goals for my team.
But the way that you were
describing it, saying--
making that
specific, like I want
to research this
particular thing
or learn about
this type of model
can really help you
understand where
your team is spending
their time and can give you
some insight into those
things to stay on top of.
So I liked that as an idea.
Thank you for sharing.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Let's see.
Santiago, you also had some
thoughts there to share,
if you wanted to jump in too.
And I didn't mean to
put anybody on the spot.
I was just reading
through the chat there.
Oh, no worries.
I didn't put my mic in.
Yeah.
So I subscribe to a
ton of newsletters,
and it clutters your inbox.
I have a whole separate
email account just
to stay on top of these things.
But there are a ton of good
resources that are free.
One will summarize arc phase,
or whatever that is, papers,
like top 10 papers
of the last month
or whatever, most are
deep learning related,
some are stats.
There's a couple of deep
learning newsletters
that are really good.
And then, I'm a
member of the ASA,
and they send out
daily webinars.
And there's all kinds of good
stuff, geospatial, temporal,
time series, there's one
today on something later.
And then, through
one of those there's
a quick shout-out for something
that I thought was really cool.
Somebody named Cynthia
Rudin at Duke and her team
developed a series of models.
One I think it's called ghost.
I don't know if I'm
saying that right.
But it's a really
cool, interpretable,
has a high performance.
Cool.
That's awesome.
I was just trying to type
in to find the link to it.
If you have it and want to
share it in the chat too.
To any of the
stuff I mentioned?
Or yeah, the ghost model
you were just mentioning.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah, sure.
And her papers are
interpretable too,
for anyone that's
interested in it.
I will shut up now
and put some links in.
Thank you.
I just wanted to
remind everybody
as well that you can
just raise your hand here
and if you want to
ask some questions.
Or if you want to put
some into the Slido chat,
we can reshare that link.
I always forget
that when you join,
if it doesn't show you
the messages that were
there before in the Zoom chat.
But Yu, when we were
talking about networking
and different companies
that you reached out to,
the past few months,
we've featured
a lot of different
pharma customers
that have been collaborating
together on a few open source
projects.
And I was curious if
there are things like that
happening in the finance space?
That's finance-based.
About the network,
do I reach out
to the data leaders known as
leaders from other finance
program?
Yeah.
Or if there's an organization
where a lot of finance leaders
get together, or data
science, finance leaders.
Right now, I will say no.
Because of the financial
services industry,
it's a very small world.
So people know each other.
And they only hire people
they know-- they only
hire-- they like to hire people
who they work before-- who they
work with before.
So it's you don't
need to network.
You don't need to network
with other people.
You just know everybody
working in this small circle.
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
But again, networking,
I would say
it's super important concept.
It's also what I learned
from the EMBA program.
So to network, it's
not just you find
some people who can help you.
But another equally
important opportunity
is you can find opportunities
for you to help others.
So you will grow as
people who, either people
who are being sponsored by
other leaders, as well as people
who sponsor the growth
of other people.
So this is, for me, I believe
this idea makes a lot of sense.
I think for a lot of people
networking can sound scary
[LAUGHS] sometimes.
And I'm wondering if you have
any tips for people on how
to first reach out to somebody.
I don't know.
I think it's part
of people's nature.
If you are some super extrovert,
it's very easy for you
to talk to anyone or people
always talk to other people.
Again, if you are introvert,
it doesn't matter.
But for me, networking
is first you just need
to be genuine, that's for sure.
And again, don't go to--
don't go to a networking event
with the idea, I need to figure
out a new model algorithm
that I do not know right now.
So just be open,
and just, I just
want to try to make
some new friends.
I think this is
the starting point.
And later, gradually,
if you become
friends with other people,
then during the conversation,
ideas, opportunities will
grow, will rise up naturally.
Thank you.
So I think this was maybe
50 minutes or so ago,
you mentioned being an
ambassador to the data science
program or data
science community.
And I was curious
what that meant.
And do you have a data
science community within--
No.
But I mean, because data science
is, it's kind of a catchy word,
a lot of people are
very interested in this.
People say, we don't know
a lot about data science.
But we know it's used by
almost every business.
So whenever any group
in any community,
I will always try to
explain to them what
data science is, what I do.
For example, again, go
back to the EMBA program.
The current EMBA
program, I mean,
the EMBA Americas Program,
it has maybe 170 students
in the cohort.
But I'm the only data science
professional in that cohort.
So people are curious
what do you do?
What do you want to pursue?
Be prepared.
Your job looks--
sounds more technical.
So what do you want to do?
Why do we want to
join the EMBA program?
But that's why I believe
I'm the ambassador here.
So I always say, because--
and again, for the EMBA
program, the background
of your classmates and
colleagues can be very diverse.
For example, in my program,
in the Dallas boardroom,
people from Dallas, we
have a business owner
of our fabrication business.
We have a seasoned
officer of American--
of the Special Operations
of the American Army.
We have people-- we
have a head of sales
of another financial
organization.
We have people from
the pharma industry.
But again, that's why it's
super interesting and super cool
if you--
OK, this is a data science.
This is what I do,
and this is what
I believe data science
can do for you in your--
for your job, for your business.
And I believe this is a very
cool-- there's always good
conversation there.
And when you share your
experience and knowledge
with people who is holding the
similar type of-- similar title
to you, but from
a different field,
this is how you open your mind
and how you grow up from there.
And again, probably I want
to spend about five minutes
to talk about the EMBA program.
Because I feel a
lot of people here,
because again,
people, if you believe
that you want to pursue a
high quality EMBA program,
you do not want
to quit your job,
you don't want to
move to another city
to where the school is.
The citing of the
Cornell EMBA program
is very unique, because
it's called a course.
It has distributed classrooms
in maybe 10, about 20 big cities
in North America, maybe both
United States and Canada.
It's a joint program
sponsored-- provided
by both Cornell University
in the United States
and Queen's
University of Canada.
And so, usually, every
other weekend you
go to the classroom
in your city.
And you'll meet your customer--
meet your classmates in person.
So you have this face
to face experience.
And then, the class itself
will be taught by a professor
still--
I'l endorse it.
And it's a team-based, because
other students there, they
are the leaders, executives.
If you just need to
take a class and do
some individual homework,
it doesn't matter.
For me, I don't
care about grades.
I got an A, I got a C, it
that's a matter for me.
At least I know what I learned.
So but if there is
a teammates, you
need to work on team
project, so OK, I
represent team Dallas here.
I need to do a good job.
I cannot just--
I should not just spend
a little time on that.
OK, I need to do a good job.
I decided to make sure that all
the students are highly engaged
and make sure that
it's competitive.
So I believe that, I mean,
personally I believe it's--
Maybe I'm embarrassed, but I
believe it's other people here,
because for our area,
it's a big commitment,
a big financial commitment, and
it's a big commitment of time,
trust me.
So I have other choices.
But if you go to
other universities,
they said that every
other weekend you
need to travel there,
take two days of classes,
and then go back.
It's not just travel
because the classes--
it's very super demanding.
You need to spend a lot
of time on homework,
prepare the exam, that
these kind of things.
So probably if that time if
you want to go to EMBA program,
and with a--
maybe from a top tier
Ivy League school,
that's a good
choice, because you
can do it from your own city.
Thank you.
That's great to know.
Yeah, I've been thinking about
it a little bit myself as well.
Maybe shifting--
and I keep hearing
LinkedIn dinging somewhere,
and I don't know where it is.
[LAUGHS] Trying to shut it off.
But maybe shifting gears
just a little bit here.
I've recently been talking
to a few people who
are maybe moving to the cloud.
And I was curious
if that's something
that your team is doing, or
what your toolset is like.
Yes.
This is our direction.
So we use-- we just build out--
we have an on-prem server.
So it's a Linux server.
So it's a big server.
So it's shared by all the
data science in my team--
data scientists in my team.
And we build the models there.
And we implement it in
our own IT environment.
Starting capacity will begin
to shift into a zero machine
learning studio.
So the shift happens now.
So again, after that, so
it's we are still exploring
all the functions, all
the options we have there.
But we believe
this is the future.
I realized, Alan, we kind
of went on the same wavelength
there at the exact same time.
[LAUGHS] Do you want to jump
in with your question too?
It was really similar.
And I think we spoke to
it a little bit already.
Maybe the only thing
to tack on would
be, as you think about
moving to cloud then,
do you have a bunch
of negotiation
that you have to do within the
organization for approvals,
or security reviews,
or that kind of stuff?
Just curious in general
about the level of autonomy
that you and your
team have versus
needing to play in the space
that the rest of the company
is ready to set up for you.
Oh, there are.
But frankly, all
the negotiations
happens at higher level.
I didn't make the decisions.
That happens at
the top, top level.
Of course, we had a chance to
review all the products to give
them recommendations.
Like we have this
concern on that function.
So probably we need
to figure that out.
That's our input to that shift.
And they know that you're
there as stakeholders.
So are they asking
you like, hey, we've
got an enterprise plan for
cloud whatever coming along.
Help us make sure it's good?
Or do you have to
be really assertive
and remind them that
you exist as a function
and need to be able to input?
Oh, I think we got
to the assertive way.
So we make some very
clear requirements.
So because we are
financial industry,
we have some more
sensitive customer
called PII, personal
identification, and some data.
We said, so data security
is our top concern.
So we gave them a
specific list of needs.
We need to make sure
this, and this, and this,
and then they figured
out, we can help
you meet all the requirements.
Got it.
Cool.
Thank you.
One anonymous question
that's over on Slido
is, what is the biggest
challenge or project
that you and your team are
trying to tackle right now?
If you say biggest
challenge, well, building--
traditionally, we are building a
lot of machine learning models.
So I won't say any of--
some of them are more
difficult than others.
But I won't say that
any specific ones
are especially challenging.
One thing we are
doing right now is
we are trying to build
some optimization models.
My major is operations research.
So it's not predict model,
it's the machine learning.
For example, some of
traveling salesman,
I guess, I'm sure some
people just know that.
And this is new
field for my team.
And it's I won't say
it's challenging,
but it's very interesting.
So for example, we want
to-- we have our sales team.
They need to visit
different dealers.
So it's a kind of classic
traveling salesman problem.
That we have these dealers,
we know their location.
So basically, we
have the distance
between every two points.
And then we know the
starting point, probably
the home base of the
salesman, or sales manager.
And then every
day, a manager only
travel a certain amount,
a certain number of miles,
can only visit a certain
number of dealers.
And then, for each dealer,
we have our expectations.
So probably a potential benefit.
A visit.
And then we need to build an
optimization model to say,
finally, given this, tell
dealer sales manager what?
On Monday, this is
the list of dealers
we think you should visit.
And we also give them miles.
You can start from dealer
A, and after A, you
travel to dealers C,
and then this comes in.
This is the project we
are working right now.
The challenging part
is the implementation.
And because it can be very
complicated, because a dealer
sales manager, they may
have different home base.
And maybe the area or the
territory he or she manages
is so big.
And then, you need to
add some other concerns,
like how much time he can travel
in the morning, how much time
he can travel in the afternoon.
If you add all the
constraints, the problem
can get more complicated.
So right now this is the
problem we are trying to tackle.
Also, it's a challenging one.
Thank you.
Another question over on
Slido is, is your group
considered a revenue generator?
Have you or your team
developed something which
made higher-ups take notice?
Yeah.
I would say, absolutely.
Because actually, I
asked the same question
while I take the accounting
class in the EMBA program.
I said, so our
program, we shall we
be considered as revenue
generator or not?
[LAUGHS] And the
professor said, yes,
because you generate
a lot of, I mean,
in intelligent--
intelligent assets.
So and especially for
the financial services,
for the lending
industry, data science--
it's driven by data science.
Because you'll have
a lot of money here.
And a lot of people will
reach out to you to say,
could you borrow me some money?
I want to finance my vehicle.
And if you cannot use your data
science to mitigate the risk
well, to make the rejection,
to make the approval or decline
decision wisely, then you
will lose all your hand very
quickly.
So because of this,
I believe that is,
again, definitely data science
is core part of the revenue
generator of our business.
Thank you.
I am not sure how to
ask this question.
But so I just watched
recently The Big Short.
And so, I'm just--
I'm curious if there
are certain things
that you have to do
as a data science team
to make sure that
certain areas aren't
lending to too many people who
might not be able to pay back.
Looking at individual areas
as compared to others?
Could you rephrase
the question?
So lending too many people?
Well, I guess I'm, yeah,
Libby is helping me out there.
Managing the risk
with subprime loans,
do you have to look at
individual locations
versus others, or
individual dealers?
OK, gotcha.
Of course.
Yes.
So let me explain
it a little bit.
It's very interesting,
the subprime industry.
So basically, the
principal business, that we
have a lot of money.
We are trying to lend them out.
We will start from the
safest customer segment.
And they will keep
lending, lending, lending,
and then the risk
of the portfolio
will increase,
increase, increase,
until it reaches the
threshold of reach to a level,
the risk is too high.
We'll stop.
And then, again, in
this whole process,
the risk is just measured
by a lot of machine
learning models we build.
For example, we receive an
application from a customer
say, I need to borrow
$10,000 to buy a car.
The first thing we need to do is
whether we approve or decline.
And then we use bureau data,
we use some alternative data,
like payday loans, these kind
of things, to build a model,
to make a decision, maybe
in 10 or 15 seconds.
And then say, OK,
if we approve it,
how decline this application.
If approved, then there are
some other decisions to make.
So if approve it,
what's the price?
What's the APR we should charge?
What kind of deal
we can provide?
The customer will said, I want
to borrow $40,000 for a BMW.
But we built some models
where it says, sorry,
we can only approve--
we can only give you
maybe $15,000 for a Toyota.
This is determined by the model.
And after that, there are
also another similar series
of models like probably
if we booked a deal, if we
booked a loan, I will say that.
So if we have the
loan in the portfolio,
we'll be motivated,
well, so what's
the default risk of this loan
during the entire life cycle?
So we call the post-funding
models, something like that.
And then we need to
have models manage it.
So if the loan--
how shall we service this loan?
So if the customer is
a very risky customer,
we shall call them every
month to say that you
need to make the payment.
Or is it our core
customer, we can just
let him or her manage
the payment herself--
by himself or herself.
So either way, there are a
bunch of, I would say, credit,
we call scorecards, a
bunch of credit risk models
behind the loan origination
and loan servicing
the subprime industry.
And this is what my team do.
And this is the
product of my team.
And this is super interesting
because as a subprime,
the risks are high.
If for people, a lot of people,
most people in this audience,
if we belong to the
prime or super prime,
if the credit
score is very high,
you do not need these models.
You just need an Excel table.
They just need to pull
your bureau score.
And then based on table, say
this guy is in this interval,
this is the interest
rate we will charge.
That's it.
Sorry.
Thank you.
I see two more
questions that I think
we could cover before
the top of the hour.
But Emilio, I see, you
just asked a question.
Do you want to jump in?
And I can read it if--
OK.
Oh, I see you unmuted.
EMILIO: Yeah, sure.
Hi.
How did the COVID
experience affected
your parameter estimation
process or your overall scoring
process?
I'm sorry?
I didn't hear your question.
EMILIO: Can you hear me now?
RACHAEL DEMPSEY: I can hear you.
Yep.
YU CAO: Yep.
EMILIO: How did
COVID-19 experience
affected your process
of estimating parameters
and the overall scoring?
Thanks?
Oh, it changes
everything that occurred.
And not COVID-19 itself, just
because of the stimulation
money.
Because of stimulus money,
all the bureau scores,
they are inflated.
There is an inflation
in the bureau scores.
Because a lot of credit
bureaus, they will stop--
I mean, they will stop
taking into account
of the default and
delinquency of some trade
lines of the customers.
And then, because of
the stimulation money,
people will make extra
payments toward their debts.
Again, all of the-- a
lot of factors here,
but we found that the bureau
scores, they are inflated.
So a lot of bureau
variables, they are inflated.
And one today, when the
stimulation money went away,
that's another factor animal.
People's behavior,
they are shifting back.
And again, because
of the COVID-19,
the pandemic creates a bubble.
And now the bubble burst.
And when the people try to get
back to normal, all the risks,
they were holding
in that bubble,
now they are available now.
So people in the
past three years
during the pandemic,
a lot of loans,
they were supposed
to go default,
but they didn't because
of the maybe the stimulus
money or a lot of other pauses.
But right now, all that is over
suddenly, all of these loans,
they began to-- they
begin to become delinquent
or they begin to default. So I
mean, I saw a big, big shift.
It creates a lot of
challenges for our team.
So we are trying to manage
this processes right now.
EMILIO: Thank you.
Thank you.
I see Libby, you had a question
along similar lines as well.
Do you want to jump in?
Yeah.
I think Yu, you just kind
of answered it though,
because my question
was how has inflation
in the past year
affected things?
And you kind of
talked about that.
There was this big bubble
during the pandemic.
And then everything
changed right after.
And so, everything kind of
shifted in the other direction.
Yeah.
Again, I can give you some
more maybe other answers,
I mean, kind of supplemental.
Because first, we are trying
to build a macroeconomic model.
So using macroeconomic
factors like inflation,
GDP, unemployment rate,
these kind of things,
separate to maybe also maybe
gas prices, these type of things
to be in the model--
separate model.
It's not very predictive.
It adds a little bit predictive
power on top of everything
we have right now.
But it's kind of challenging to
implement microeconomic model
into our decision process.
And the other thing is that
because of our industry,
we are software industry.
So a lot of our customers
they are contractors.
Maybe they work in
Target, Walmart, others.
So inflation, I would say,
didn't impact them absolutely.
But the impact is not that much.
So again, not just inflation.
Right now the tech
layoff, because all
the high tech companies, they
are starting to lay off people.
And so, because the
wave is-- the impact
hasn't reach out to
our business right now.
Just because our customers
are different from the people
being impacted right now.
Thank you, Yu.
Thank you.
One last question that I see
I had missed over on Slido.
The question was, do you use
R, Python, SAS, or Excel, VBA,
and in what mix?
Are there legacy
systems in your industry
that you must deal with?
Well, I joined the
company in finance,
the whole modeling
process was in SAS.
At that time, I know
almost nothing about SAS.
So I just fake it.
So I know, I know SAS,
[LAUGHS] and then kind of--
But at that time,
I know R a lot.
So fortunately, at that time
we were transitioning from SAS
to R. And then, I started to
build our whole pipeline in R.
And then, right now, I would
say that our model pipeline is
our templates, I
would say is 95% in R.
Again, in the future,
R is very nice.
I like R a lot.
But in future, from the
implementation perspective,
Python is more convenient.
And again, you will see
a lot of machine learning
papers, algorithms.
When they also they
publish a paper,
they just build a Python library
and then throw it in GitHub.
That's it.
I reach out, and can
you write an R version?
They say, no thanks.
[LAUGHS]
So right now, I will
say, I want our people
in my team to be bilingual,
so we can code in R,
we can code in SAS--
We can code in R, we
can code in Python.
For SAS, we still
use it for model
for reporting perspective
to generate some reports,
but that's it.
For Excel, VBA, we use a little
bit to build some, because we,
for example, we don't--
we do, ah, if you want
to do ad hoc analysis,
Excel is very convenient.
And sometimes, if you want to
build a summary part and model
summary, model documentation,
we have some VBA in Excel
to generate some figures.
Great.
Thank you so much, Yu.
I know we have just crossed
over the top of the hour here.
But before we let you
go, I was just curious
what's the best way for people
to get in touch with you?
Is it LinkedIn?
Yeah.
Automatically.
And email, LinkedIn
profile, you can also
find my cell phone number.
So you reach out to me if
you have any questions.
[LAUGHS]
Awesome.
I was going to try and go copy
it over here very quickly,
but somebody might be able
to do it faster than me.
Oh, here you are.
I'll put your LinkedIn here.
There you are.
Well, thank you so much, Yu,
joining us today and sharing
your experience.
It's been great
learning from you.
Yeah.
Thank you, Rachael.
Thank you for your team.
It's a great event,
and thank you
for all the people
joining this event today.
Thanks a lot.
It's nice to talk to you.
See everybody next
week, hopefully.
Have a great rest of the week.